you're looking at right there my dog
Emma she is a Basenji pit mix she's
about 12 years old I got her when she
was about 2 years old at the beginning
of the summer of 2005 I got her in New
York at the Humane Society and she was a
rescue from Hurricane Katrina she
actually gave birth in New Orleans
during the hurricane they found her in a
cardboard box she had just given birth
with three puppies and she was nursing
the puppies to health while she was
actually extremely sick with ringworm
and all kinds of stuff and they were
drinking all that sludge and there was
no access to food and the heat and all
that other stuff and then the hurricane
was in the end of August in 2004 she was
so sick that she actually wasn't able to
be adopted for about ten months after
they had sent the dogs all over the
place and I wanted to show Emma because
I she's now 12 and I've had her for a
long time and I love her and of course I
mean I've ever seen a better Instagram
by the way my filtering skills are
getting pretty good but I wanted to just
say for a moment about how important it
is to rescue dogs I know everybody talks
about this a lot but there are still so
many pet stores that are selling dogs
and all these dog breeders and I know
they're not all awful everyone wants to
pin them as awful people and I know that
there's some responsible breeders and
all that but there are so many wonderful
wonderful animals that you can rescue
and not only when you rescue an animal
not only are you rescuing that animal
right there
but also those shelters can only fit so
many animals so they have to put down
animals when the shelter's overflow so
you're really doing a beautiful thing
and when you buy a dog unfortunately you
really should know that in a weird way
you're actually killing one of those
shelter animals because there's only so
many houses that these dogs owns only so
many homes that these animals can go to
so if I can be on my animal soapbox for
a second you really should adopt instead
of instead of buying and you'll save
some money and you'll get a great dog
she's part she's part pit and part
Basenji Basenji is known as the barkless
dog she's quiet she's great she's been a
momma and you should see the nipples on
this thing she's got great nipples but
yeah adopt don't buy a dog save some
money save on life more importantly than
that and and then they'll lick
yeah she's always licking I think we
just lost the image wearily she's
licking she's a good liquor and and
there are man's best friend